this is the beyond satisfiability
workshop at the simons
which is running now as
a virtual weekly seminar instead of a
focused workshop during the week and
so this tuesday uh where
uh our speaker is ambrose glexner
uh who is heading the
mathematical optimization methods group
at the souza institute in berlin
in particular this group is
um has produced the the
skip mixed integer programming solver
and the supplex
linear programming solver uh which
i guess has a fair claim to being like
the best uh
academic mip solver i guess can i say
that tom bros
yes i would say so so skip definitely is
the fastest that you can
obtain in source code where you can look
at the source code
and i guess it's also fair to say that
this research group has been
also feeding quite some talent into
places like like like gurubhi and
seaplex where
they add a few commercial secrets that
mere mortals cannot
be attributed uh quite a lot of uh
previous skip developers are now working
for kurobi seplex
fico and some others of the new mib
solvers that are currently coming up
it's quite an
active field i have the feeling also
with uh
asian players entering the market so
it's
exciting so yeah and this is what what
ambrose will will tell us about today i
think there is going to be like this it
looked like a
somewhat of a introduction gentle
introduction to to mip solving and then
get into more and more of the details
and in particular
uh i'm hoping that we'll get to talk of
some of the
challenges for for how to deal with
with you know floating point issues into
exact mip solving and also how to
certify
correctness of results for mip solders
which has arguably
arguably been a bit of a maybe weak spot
so far so without further ado ambrose
please yeah so thank you jacob for this
kind of introduction
um uh yes so
it is definitely true that in the mix in
the classical mixed integer programming
community
i think the drug has been the need for
speed
more than the need for
being like 100 exactly correct
um also of course numerical stability is
very high on the agenda
because these mip solvers are heavily
used in practice
and lots of ill-conditioned data is
thrown at them and they are amazingly
stable
um with this regard but um yeah my
personal interest is also
to be even even more strict in a yeah in
a
mathematical sense of exactness and to
develop the algorithms where you get an
exact and certifiable answer and here in
the title i've written
exact mixed integer programming over the
rational numbers
um and yeah let's see why this is
important for the algorithms that i will
present
so um the title of the workshop
is beyond satisfiability and i think
mixed integer programming
perfectly fits uh fits that theme
um here is a very overloaded slide of a
few points that i wanted to mention in
the beginning
so obviously map is a generalization of
set um
and it is so for several reasons so
first of all we do have an objective
function
our main goal is or is mostly
to optimize a linear
objective function that is different
than set
but not only that additionally we
have more general types of constraints
so any linear inequality or equality
can appear and here in this notation
i've written it in matrix notation
a x less than or equal to b um but
obviously this is just a list of uh yeah
linear inequalities or equalities
uh nothing fancy what i've pointed out
is that
uh rather important is a special type of
constraints and these are the variable
bound constraints
and that also points to different a
third point in which we are more general
than set
the types of variables that appear so we
do not only have binary variables also
in the most typical applications binary
variables
modeling yes and no decisions are vital
and the solvers
are heavily biased towards performing
well
on on problems where
binary structure appears
but not only so
variables can be general integer
that means they have larger bounds than
zero and one they can be
continuous and take any
value in the real numbers and
the bounds can even be missing so there
may be unbounded variables among them
which
also as we will see can create some
trouble
when you want to solve these things
exactly
but uh so yeah i've i've
written here that the continuous
variables are from
the domain of real values but one thing
that is nice
is if the input data is rational
and by that i mean if the
objective function
[Music]
c and the coefficients in the
constraints and the right hand sides and
the bounds are all rational values
then a rational answer always exists
so i mean there are actually three types
of answers that a mip can have
right one it could be infeasible that
the constraints are
contradictory then it could be
unbounded in the sense that arbitrarily
good solutions can exist
so solutions with arbitrarily small
objective value or
the problem is bounded and there is a
finite optimum and in the last two cases
we actually always
know that um um
yeah a rational optimal solution exists
why is that
so in the bounded case so when you fix
the integer
values um to
a certain value um and
then what you obtain is a linear program
this linear program
always has a basic solution
we say this is a solution where a number
of
constraints hold with equality and so we
can determine the solution values by
solving a linear system of equations
and if the coefficient matrix and the
right hand side is rational then
also the solution will be rational and
so also there exist
irrational answers uh we can restrict
ourselves to rational ones
and the nice thing is that we even know
that
these rational answers
can be chosen to have a polynomial
size in the encoding of the input data
so if we restrict ourselves to these
basic solutions then
they will not have exponentially large
denominators or enumerators
[Music]
yes so maybe to say something about
the visualization that you see on the
right
so mixed integer programming is
definitely above
set uh important subclass is of course
if we do not have any continuous
variables so
we say we have just an integer uh
program or if we have no integer
variables and then we are left only with
a linear program
so linear programs are interesting
in itself but also for solving mixed
integer programs
as we will see because they appear as
subroutines in the classical
lp based branch and part algorithm so
[Music]
of course there are further
generalizations
you can allow for non-linear
constraints which brings you to mixed
into non-linear programming
or you can even go further
and allow holes in your domains or
other general types of constraints
then then you would end up in the field
of constrained programming
um so maybe just a bit of history uh the
solver skip that has come out of to the
institute
um was initially started in order to
form
a combination of yes
mixed integer programming techniques
satisfiability techniques especially
conflict-driven clause learning
and techniques from constrained
programming like domain propagation
and the say problem class that
using all these combinations of solving
techniques
we can solve efficiently in a branch and
bound framework
was coined constrained integer
programming
um so this is not so much of a program
of a problem class but rather of an
algorithmic concept which tries to
integrate these different techniques
um this integration has become pretty
standard today
in mixed integer programming solver so
uh skip is not
the only uh solver that does that also
others
have taken over things like conflict
driven course learning into
uh into their repertoire so um
maybe also to compare to set so the
appeal of mixed integer programming
um is yeah uh the
same and different reasons uh then what
makes set solvers appealing so uh also
in the mip community we have
black box solvers um that's quite nice
in practice because
modeling and algorithm design is
separated and we have experts that
deal with solving these and experts that
deal with modeling
and that also helps to bring them into
practice
but also most of these solvers are yeah
open box in the sense that you can
extend them
by problem specific techniques skip as
an open source solver is of course a
prime example for this but
not only also close to us commercial
solvers have a tradition
of allowing to add supplementary
techniques during the solving process
so this has made it quite effective um
also for academic researchers to use
some of these closed source
solvers and to do research with them
and then a special point is maybe
uh that mip solvers uh provide
global optimality guarantees to the
answers
so um we do not
simply find good solutions that are
feasible and have
yeah good
optimal objective but we always even if
the solution is not successful
completely
uh provide um a guarantee
on how far the best solution could be uh
off
from the solution that was found and uh
that
allows two things uh so first of all you
can use these solvers as heuristics
you do not have to run them to
global optimality but you can also use
this gap that you get
in order to stop early if you do not
require
a higher say precision precision in the
sense of
objective quality and so that has made
them
quite attractive also in practice so two
questions
so one yes this fact that you have a
is somehow a feature of how the like mip
algorithms
work that you always maintain uh like
both an upper and a lower bound and then
they get closer and closer
exactly yes correct and then
armin beer asks when we talk about
polynomial
out like the solution in polynomial size
in terms of the input or we
this is in terms of bit size like
polynomial number bits in
okay uh yes so if we represent the
numbers in
binary encoding yeah okay thanks
so we have kind of logarithmic in like
input size is logarithmic uh in the in
the
actual numbers and the output size is
measured of course in the same
way um yeah so please uh always
interrupt me i cannot
see the chat here while i'm presenting
but do not hesitate
so um jacob has already mentioned it
so before so the special topic of this
talk is actually
how do we solve this without any
numerical errors
but i think before i can do that as the
first talk who talks about mixed integer
programming i should
give at least a short introduction uh to
the algorithmic paradigm that i'm
considering that is
the state of the art for most
mid-solvers
and this i will do in the first section
uh and
then in the second one uh present the
sort of the trouble that we are in um
when we use floating point arithmetic
and uh
give a short overview of what what has
been done so far
so what are kind of the fastest
algorithms that
guarantee exact results um so far
i mean until like beginning of the year
because we've just recently published
a new version of uh exact
uh skip an
exact version of the skip solver that
improves upon
this in several aspects and that will be
the content of the third section
um then i would conclude
this first part of the workshop
uh today with the conclusion we can have
some discussion um
and then yes we are open to dive deeper
into two topics the first one would be
how to actually solve linear programs
exactly
and the second topic would be how to
verify
the results that are such an executive
solver gives
certificates and i'm perfectly fine to
skip any of these
we will see after the conclusion i guess
how to continue so
let's get started with an introduction
to rip solving
um so
mib is uh np hard and so the common
approach
to tackle such problems would be to yeah
not directly try to solve them but to
compute first of all bounce on the
optimal value
and balance of two types of course so
one would be
an underestimation of the optimal value
we also call this a dual bound
that is obtained typically by a
relaxation
so we increase the we
relax and remove some of the
restrictions on feasibility and
classically how we do that
is that we remove the integral integer
restrictions so all variables become
continuous
um this way we obtain a convex
optimization problem which is
um theoretically fast to solve but also
in practice often
uh it works quite well and this gives us
a solution
and both an actual solution
which is infeasible because other
variables are fractional but
also a lower bound on the objective
function value and then the second bound
is would be an upper bound so if we are
lucky and find a feasible solution that
satisfies all constraints and the
integrality restrictions
then we have a bound u
we call this the primal bound as well
and uh this is obtained by two uh
in two ways so first of all we could be
lucky and the lp relaxation is
accidentally feasible
then of course we are optimal optimal
at the current point so maybe with some
for looking at some sub problems so not
optimal for
the whole problem but also there are in
the solvers
implemented a lot of supplementary
techniques so called primal heuristics
which try to
find good solutions but have no
guarantees on doing so
and are also trying to
be fast in the sense of
not being shy to fail if it doesn't look
doesn't look good
and yeah when you have now these two
types of bounds what you can then
implement is a classic divide and
conquer approach
so this gap that you have between the
upper and the lower bound u minus l
can be systematically reduced um by
subdividing the solution space and how
this is classically done
is by taking an integer variable that
takes a fractional value
in the linear programming relaxation
and use this to construct two sub
problems
uh one where you say less than or equal
to
the round down one where you say the
variable must be greater than equal to
round up
um and since we have finitely many uh
values and uh if the
integer values are bounded and this
converges
schematically we always look at this
like a branch in bound tree which is
here
on the left-hand side if we go down to
the sub-problems then
this is applied recursively and as i
already said if we are lucky and the
linear programming relaxation is
accidentally integer feasible
then we find an
improved upper bound
and the first a feasible solution and
if we stop uh at some point after this
then even if we have not converged uh to
a gap of zero
um still we have an answer that can be
implemented in practice
and we even have a gap that tells us
how far we may be off from the optimal
objective
value yes so in this animation
we find we don't find the optimal
solution
at the first time but only when we
consider one of the later
nodes the schematic view on the left
hand side
is of course not very accurate so here
is an attempt
to visualize this process a bit better
this is a branch in boundary
where in the x-wise
plane we we
have used multi-dimensional scaling
to project the linear programming
relaxations that we obtained during the
branch boundary at each of the nodes
which of course live in a very high
dimension space to project that to
2d so multi-dimensional scaling tries to
somehow preserve the distances
and so what you see there at the very
bottom are these projections
of the linear programming relaxations
and then in the
z direction uh going up you see
these linear programming realizations
aligned with
their objective value um
and they are connected uh in the same
way that
you would connect them schematically in
the branch and bound uh tree
sketch so at the very bottom you see the
initial node which we also call the root
node
it has yeah the lowest the worst
dual bound that we find initially
and then you see uh the this lower bound
l the dual bound increases as the
algorithm progresses
and the first thing so i'm not sure can
you actually see my
mouse pointer here
yes yes we can see your mind so yeah so
this is here the root note and then
first of all you see a line that doesn't
even divide but just goes to kind of a
second root node
what happens here is that we improve the
tightness of the relaxation
will come to this later and obtain in a
better
lower bound but then starting from here
actually this branching happens you
subdivide
into two different sub problems by
probably branching on a binary variable
fixing the value to zero and to one and
you see also here
the lower bound increases slightly
and this continues recursively and
the green yeah
the green lines here
indicate the level at which the optimal
integer
objective lies you see that some of the
uh nodes here exceed this
optimal objective this is quite
natural so the when you fix
more and more variables your dual bound
gets uh worse and worse so it increases
increases and um it may even increase
to a level uh which is sub-optimal so
such that in the in the sub tree below
you will not find
the optimal solution anymore and um if
you already know an upper bound you and
you've exceeded this upper bound
then you know that you can stop this
search so you do not need to complete
your enumeration
this is called pruning and um
[Music]
this is of course one of the things that
makes this whole approach even feasible
i would say if whip solvers are
successful then usually this
happens because they somehow tricked out
the usual exponential
blow up that you obtain for np hard
problems and one of these tricks
is i mean it's not a
systematic thing that you can prune
subtrees that are proven to be
suboptimal
because of the lp bound um
[Music]
so this is just a very quick uh
run through um yeah this branch and
bound paradigm
um but uh let's
look at what happened here at the very
beginning um so
where i said we are not even branching
and the lower bound improves how can
this
happen well the most important way this
happens is that
we add so-called cutting planes so this
you see here on
the right side where the
blue region or let's start like the blue
dots
are all the integer feasible points um
of our problem the blue region now is
kind of the tightest the convex hull of
these integer points so
sort of the tightest polytope that we
can
lay around around these integer feasible
points
but unfortunately it is the case that
the linear programming
relaxation that we obtain when we drop
the integrality requirements
is not this tightest relaxation this
blue region
but it is a bit larger and you see it
here indicated by this gray line
so this is not surprising
because if if if we would get this blue
region for free say
then somehow mip would be easy we would
just solve the linear program we would
arrive at one of these vertex solutions
here
and these vertex solutions would always
be integer feasible and then we would be
done
in polynomial time that cannot be the
case so usually we obtain a point like
this in red
which is further away from this convex
hull and has some fractional components
and now i already said the standard way
of the the the
what what branch and bound does is it
resolves this fractionality by
subdividing the problem into two parts
um there is another algorithm to do so
to kind of
remove this infeasible fractional
solution from
our relaxation that is to add a
cutting plane which is a inequality
that is valid for all of the integer
feasible solutions but violates
is violated by the current lp solution
and as a matter of fact
this cutting plane approach could be run
exclusively
so as a matter of fact historically the
cutting plane approach
uh pre-dates the branch and bound
approach in the scientific literature
which from our point of view today is
uh um actually quite interesting because
branch and bound is first of all
a bit simpler you would save from the
idea
in the theory behind and
second of all it's somehow a bit more
successful
even in practice um but
this cutting plane approach could be run
uh purely so you could just
iteratively add cutting planes and you
would know that um
with certain types of cutting planes
which are called gomorry cuts you would
in finite
time arrive at an integer feasible point
um yeah but what actually works best in
practice if you
if you combine these two so you add some
limited
number of cutting planes at the root
node but also sometimes at the
local nodes of the search tree um and by
this you improve the dual bound
you avoid some of the exponential block
that you get by branching
and in combination if you do it smartly
um
yeah you you
strongly improve upon playing branch and
bound
um
so one one reason why this works
is um because yeah the solution of
linear programs is fast
um and there's a bit more to that which
i want to make you aware of
um also to
put into perspective the uh the
algorithms that you will see later for
solving uh moves exactly and this
is uh that we are not using any
linear programming algorithm there are
many out there
but typically mib solvers use the
simplex method
and the reason is because simplex can
warm start so it's not only fast to
solve
the initial lp relaxation but there's a
huge speed up when you solve
the relaxations of this uh the nodes
where only few changes have happened to
your
parent node these few changes are
usually just one bound change right the
bound of one variable has been changed
or
one additional valid inequality has been
added
and here is an experiment that
i've conducted quite a while ago
about the average number of iterations
that the simplex algorithm needs
to solve lp relaxation this is averaged
over a larger test set
and what you see here on the left is a
table
how many iterations you would need at
the root node and
at each depth level and
on the right side you see um yeah how
how many nodes there are actually at
each depth level
so you see that over this test set
you kind of have the broadest
[Music]
frontier at about level 18
or something and after that
the effect of pruning kicks in heavily
so either pruning
by sub-optimality which i've explained
before or
because simply the lp relaxation becomes
infeasible because
integer variables have been fixed to
values
that do not allow a feasible assignment
anymore and this is
recognized and now if you compare
the average number of iterations uh
383.7 at the root note
and 3.3 at level 17 where you have the
broadest width of the tree
then you get an approximate like
over 100 times speed up from root note
to this ep relaxation solved
inside the tree and this is really one
of the
um sometimes overlooked reasons why myth
works so i said already
it works when uh we're kind of cheating
the exponential
growth through some special techniques
that
um yeah some tricks uh that that work
for the type of formulations that we
encounter most often
and the second reason is because the
simplex and not only the simplex
algorithm in general but also
the heavily optimized implementations
that
exist today are so good in this
re-optimization such that they can
actually enumerate
a large amount of nodes obviously
maybe i should say that in that context
this is nothing compared to
satisfiability
solvers set solvers have a much higher
note throughput
and explore many more
nodes than whip solvers but
when you compare it to say other
mathematical optimization solvers
then this is still very notable and it
is
crucial so if we could even further
speed up the lp solution
many more mips that are unsolvable today
would be in reach
so this is one
there's a significant amount of mips
where the lp solving is
the actual bottleneck to reaching global
optimality
all right there are two more topics that
i want to
mention and the questions oh yeah
please so a question is is it like clear
that i mean could you also say that well
i don't know suppose that you had like
more clever branching or or
sophisticated conflict analysis then
maybe you would need to solve
like fewer lps or or it's like
um yes obviously so this is a
combination of things
but but you're saying like given given
given if you want to
like identify a bottleneck in the
current setup then like
like faster lp solving would yeah that's
i mean i don't want to say this is the
only bottleneck at all
um i just want to say there are
instances where
um which we could solve if we solved
this bottleneck so
this is a limited uh so i just want to
point out the importance of
this speed of simple uh of of
lp solving it's not an exclusive
bottleneck at all
fair enough okay thanks obviously if you
would have
sort of if you had a magical oracle of
cutting planes or
or generating a tight formulation
uh we would be solved at the root node
then usually
um yeah we wouldn't have maybe a
problem with solving lps in the north
yes that is i mean there's an
interesting parallel i don't know
to what extent there has been um
like the interactions between mip
solving and satsang in this regard
they're also called look ahead sat
solvers
that we had a seminar i think in one of
the workshops a few weeks back
where um the the best stat solders that
are used for
for like for instance for hard
combinatorial problems they typically
don't do this conflict-driven close
learning paradigm where you just
make decisions quickly and then
backtrack and do conflict analysis
instead they spend like huge amounts of
time on probing and setting different
variables
collecting statistics like if i set this
variable to true and false how will my
sub trees compare and how much
does this thing it it it seems a little
bit like
what i think you call strong branching
like you would actually try
to set every variable to like true and
false and then
really investigate how this work and
spend lots of time to compute the
statistics
and only then the look ahead solver
commits and somehow my understanding
i'm not in this area at all i think some
people in the audience like
bira it seems like to be here could
correct but
my understanding is that that you spend
tons of time on this look ahead solving
but that
helps you to at least heuristically like
keep the decision tree depth
shallower because you're making so good
decisions but yeah
yes so and maybe this is also something
to mention for mips alvarez whip solver
spend much more time at a note
and so we also in advance i think we
spend
more time to really try to figure out
the right
decisions like in branching in order not
to create extra work
um because just throwing like restarting
like in set or in conflict with
closer learning is so much more
expensive in mip that
it's not feasible in the same way
yeah i think that's a nice parallel
thanks so yeah there are two more things
that i want to point out
i mean why these mips always work in
practice because they have many
additional
supplementary techniques um
and i picked now two because this is
something where we made
and now an advancement in respect to
exact solving
the first is pre-solving um which goes a
bit in the direction of what you
mentioned currently i believe
also and the second one is primary
heuristics
um so pre-solving is an important phase
in classical mip solvers
to improve the formulation it's in some
sense
something that has a similar goal like
cutting planes but
works even earlier here's a small
example to motivate this so there's one
technique called precision strengthening
on a small problem here on the left side
you see a two variable problem again the
blue region
is oh no actually not again so here the
blue region is really the lp relaxation
which you see is um not the convex hull
of the integer feasible points which are
marked in black
and now coefficient strengthening is a
very cheap technique that
um can figure out that the inequality
can be tightened
uh significantly to x1 plus x2 is less
than equal to one
and then on the right side you see
actually you have reached the the
state that the
the lp relaxation is the convex hull
of the integer feasible points and so on
the left below you see
that a branching tree would enumerate
[Music]
through depth too until it
finds the optimal solution and certifies
it
but on the right side if we have a
stronger problem then
yes we're done after the root note
because all we need is to solve the lp
relaxation and this will be immediately
integer feasible at least if we use a
simplex solver that always returns a
basic solution
and so this is one of the things that
pre-solving tries to
achieve like you spend very little time
but
improve the formulation significantly
the second thing would be to reduce the
size by simply removing
fixed variables constraints that
are not tight
and and the like and
then two more points should be mentioned
we also try to
extract structure so identify
implications between binary variables
if one variable is set to zero then
another variable has to have at least
this
tight lower bound or something like this
or mutually exclusive assignments not
both
binary variables can be set to one and
this can then be later
used during the solving process for
instance to create cutting planes but
also also other in heuristics or in
other places
symmetry detection would also be
something that falls into this category
um we will not focus on on that in
detail
in this talk uh maybe the last one is
um also crucial we try to improve
numerics mostly with respect to the lp
solver
so the episode has to do yeah a lot with
finding a numerically
uh reliable solution to the continuous
relaxation and things that hurt there
are of course
large coefficients and so if pre-solving
can reduce the size of the coefficients
it would try to do so there are two
different types of
reductions that pre-solving can do first
one is just
feasibility reasoning so
you do not cut off any feasible
solutions but
uh just like in this motivating example
of coefficient strengthening
cut off infeasible fractional solutions
um but then there's also some reasoning
that uses the objective function
and may even remove feasible solutions
as long as at least one optimal solution
remains
so it may even cut off optimal solutions
yes at least one optimal solution
has has to remain and
[Music]
yeah so the the impact of pre-solving is
among
as strong as uh cutting planes for
instance when you
do an experiment of turning it off
versus turning it on
you lose as much performance as if you
would turn off tapping planes so this is
really
uh significant not only in terms of
speed but also in terms of the
number of instances that you can solve
when you say that you actually remove
optimal solutions
but you make sure some other solutions
that are also
still there this would be like symmetry
arguments or other types of arguments
symmetry is one
but another one would be also if you
have
parallel columns so you have like two
variables which
i essentially have the the same
something which
yeah the non-zero pattern is linearly
dependent
um and then you can remove
one of them increase the bounds of the
other
and then in post-processing you have to
redistribute the values again
and that is actually also some form of
symmetry
but it's a bit uh it's a bit different
and is this used again if parallel to
sat solving is that
some of these pre-processing techniques
in the in the
um very best solvers uh
they are also uh interleaved with the
actual
um search process so this is something
that's called in processing so somehow
the solver stops
and it sort of runs a pre-solving phase
a new
is this something that a map solver
would do yes that definitely happened so
we would distinguish like terminology we
would say
resolving is what happens before uh the
root note
um and during the search we would rather
call it propagation
um but essentially there's a big overlap
so
yes and then we have maybe now i thought
of a different example for this
um removal of optimal solutions
um yeah well i'm not sure if
that would remove an optimal solution
but a sub-optimal
one so if you have already an upper
bound and
you have the lp relaxation solution then
you can look at the reduced costs
which are some dual multipliers for the
variables and which tell you
if i move this variable by a bit how
much
worse does the objective bound get
so how much kind of stronger does my lp
bound get
and by this reasoning i can also exclude
some assignments i
can say this variable cannot be one
because then
the dual bound would exceed the best
primal
primal solution i've found so far so
i can actually fix it to the other side
that's what's called reduced cost
propagation and then there was a
clarification in the chat that this
look ahead solvers they don't spend tons
of time but
maybe linear time on in the size of the
formula
on on making decisions whereas cdcl
decisions are sort of made in
logarithmic time because you're just
popping
stuff off a heap so it's uh but it's
still a fairly significant
i mean it's an exponential difference in
the speed of of the decisions
yes yeah that's right i mean
also in uh in mip solving um
you have you have a trade-off right you
have to trade off
the time you spend so i would also not
say we're spending heaps of time in
pre-solving pre-solving supposed to be
very fast
but we still do spend a significant
amount of time
good and yeah so what i already
mentioned like
this reduced cost strength thing that
requires that you have an upper bound
if you've already found a primal
feasible solution
and so this is the task of primary
heuristics
um there are many different techniques
on
how to try and get lucky and find a
feasible solution that is feasible both
with respect to the constraints and with
respect to the integrality requirements
i will not go through this whole list
here just want to mention what are the
goals
so yeah we want to have a solution
available
if the process is interrupted early
and not run to full completeness but
then we also want to support the pruning
we can actually also install
this upper bound into the lp solver such
that
the lp solver does not have to be run to
optimality
um because the the
dual version of the simplex actually
approaches the objective
[Music]
from below so once it
exceeds this upper bound you it can
already stop
and does not need to run to optimality
and then the reduced cost propagation
that i mentioned
is a form of bound tightening that uses
such upper bounds
and so the idea of primary heuristics
in mip solvers is a bit different than
if you would run a heuristic
as a standalone algorithm you're not
trying to spend as much time as possible
in order to be as successful as possible
but you want to realize when you have a
chance
and when you don't and then you want to
fail fast so
it has to be effective on average but we
need to take
care that the overall effort spent on
heuristics
only
lies at a certain percentage of the
overall solving
time
yeah rounding heuristics i think is
something that everybody can imagine
that's a very fast type of heuristics
there are diving heuristics which are a
bit more sophisticated in the sense or
more expensive that
you round but you don't round all
variables at the same time and then
realize you've
you've gone wrong but in between the
roundings you
resolve the lp relaxation in order to
return to the
the the feasible region that
is given by the constraints um and so
it's more expensive but also more
successful and then a
third huge type of a huge class of
heuristics is the class of large
neighborhood search heuristics
and one example i've put up here
is the relaxation enforced neighborhood
search
which has a very simple and intuitive
idea but it demonstrates quite nicely
also how
the linear programming solution is
exploited
in many ways in whip solvers not only
for the dual bound and for the branching
so here this heuristic would look at the
relaxation and then it would distinguish
between variables that already
take an integer value in the relaxation
these are fixed all the others are
left as is we reduce
the domain uh to like the two
neighboring values so classically for
binary variable nothing would happen
but for an integer variable you would
actually convert this to sort of a
binary decision of roundup round down
and then what you get is a sub
mip which hopefully has a much smaller
size
and you can just throw your own solve at
this mip
and try to solve it to
obtain a good feasible solution of
course you don't have to solve this to
optimality
you apply heavy limits um but then this
if you are successful this may
correspond to an improved solution
in the original problem this is only one
example of
many strategies how you could fix
variables and then solve a submit
what all right so what what have we not
talked about we've not talked about
for instance conflict analysis or the
application of conflict driven
clause learning to mip we've also not
touched upon domain propagation this
uh reduced version of pre-solving that
is run at the nodes
we've not really looked at cutting
planes
and we've not at all touched upon how
symmetry is exploited
so there are many more techniques that
are sort of hidden in mib solvers but
this hopefully gave a rough idea on what
is important
for for this algorithmic design
are there any questions at this point i
think this is a good
place to stop and ask
all right if that is not the case then
yes the next point would be
um yeah what is what is actually
uh so one one
uh shortcoming of uh state-of-the-art
mib solvers today
and that is uh the use of
floating point numerics so there is
actually
one kind of question that appeared in
the chat over on youtube
which i don't know if you want to
comment on the the
zero one problems versus general integer
problems i mean if you have a general
integer and you know it's between one
and m then i guess you could replace it
either by m binary variables or even by
log
m binary variables yes kind of binary
coding
is this being done or is it preferable
to actually operate on the integers
because the problem somehow changes so
much if you
only use binary variables or no it is
definitely done
so skip also even has a pre-solving step
that performs this automatically like
compares
com replaces and bounded integer
variable
with a sum of binary variables
either uni in unary or logarithmic
encoding
um this is turned off by default because
it doesn't seem to be
good for default setting um
but uh where this
and yeah so it's i think it simply
depends on the application that this
would help
um of course where this often happens is
also
in uh in the modeling process right when
you have a scheduling problem you can
represent the times at which something a
machine is run
by an integer variable or by a bunch of
binary variables
yes or no is it run at this time yes or
no
and they are using the binaries you
usually get
much stronger formulations of course
also much larger formulations which
creates problems for solving the ap
relaxations but
from a combinatorial point of view it's
much stronger and so
typically this is preferred
this is a theoretical reason a practical
reason is
simply because mib solvers contain many
tricks to work particularly well on
formulations which have binary variables
and many of these things that you
mentioned also like strong branching
are simply either not executed or not
executed that
well when on on integer variables it's
just
um they're a bit uh i wouldn't call it
tuned they are developed
towards the binary case so there's a i
would say a good and a bad reason why
um theoretical and a practical reason
uh why you should prefer binary
variables in your modeling if you can
then there's another question which i
also guess i've been
bugging you about before so if you want
to get into set solving then we've been
marketing this handbook of
satisfiability
that has now just appeared in the second
edition like
two tomes of the gathered wisdom of the
sat community
now if someone gets so excited about by
your talk today that
they want to read the handbook of mip
solving like is there such a
work or what should they read
get up to speed on map solving that is a
very good question
so i mean this is two two uh
directions right one is the theoretical
direction which
yeah uh these deals a lot with the
theory behind the algorithms and there
are
pretty they are very good books they are
very good books on
on this um uh one
recent book would be the an integer
project called integer programming by
conforting conundrums
and co-authors if you would like to know
about
like really the tricks that are
implemented inside
practical mib solvers then there's much
fewer literature you would really need
to gather it much more from
publications and some things are not
even published
i think one very good way to start is
the phd thesis of kubia's afterback
whereas design skip
but it is certainly not complete today
since it dates back to 2007
and so i'm not aware of a handbook of
computational mip
i think it is a worthwhile project
to start
thanks
yes thank you for the questions uh so um
when when we start now talking about uh
the numerics and the floating point
numerics
um then let's start with linear
programming this is where kind of
uh things get most uh messy because
that's where you have to deal really
deal with the continuous variables and
not only with them
but with the integer values that have
been relaxed to
be continuous variables and so
[Music]
exactly speaking optimal solutions
should satisfy
the constraints without violations
they should have the bound constraints
exactly satisfied um and then
you don't only need these primal
feasibility but of course also
optimality which is called dual
feasibility in linear programming
um and rule feasibility actually
um also takes the form of an inequality
only with the transposed matrix so what
you look at are
for each variable you look at then
the column um
in the constrained matrix
for each of the constraints you get a
so-called dual variable a dual
multiplier
and now if you form a linear constraints
from this column then the
value that or the linear expression then
this
must be greater than or equal to the
objective coefficient
so that's also just a linear constraint
and it's called dual feasibility
and now the you you have basically
a a pair of solution
values one for the primer side which
are the x's for the actual variables
then one for these dual multipliers the
y's
and in order for both of them to be
to form an optimal solution they must be
complementary slack
we say so kind of the the
if the rule constraint is not
tight so if it's really larger than the
objective function coefficient then the
primal bound must be tight so then the x
value must be at zero or one
and also reverse if the variable is not
at one of its bound
then this dual constraint must hold with
equality
um and so
this is what we would actually ideally
want to have but the problem is that
these solvers implemented in floating
point arithmetic
um cannot cannot provide this they
compute solutions with
residual errors the
primal constraints are violated by up
some tolerance epsilon uh the bound
constraints might be
violated um and also this dual
feasibility constraint and this
epsilon if it works well uh
is usually chosen to be around 10 to the
minus 6 or 10 to the minus 9 so rather
small
but um
[Music]
but yeah it's not zero and um what does
that actually mean
so um this is not
an error in the space of solution so
that's one
important thing to realize this uh
this tolerance tolerances that are
used do not guarantee
that the solution that you obtain is
epsilon away from the exact solution
if you think about it what it means is
that the solution the approximate
solution that you've got
is an exact solution for a slightly
perturbed
input problem so this is also what this
second graphics is trying to
suggest so you have a slight
perturbation of the blue feasible region
and your floating point solution is now
an exact solution to this approximate
problem
of course in most cases
things work well and the solution that
you get is very close
to the actual to an actual exactly
optimal solution
but of course it can also be uh that the
problem is ill condition and this
doesn't happen it can also be
that not only this linear programming
solutions
are wrong but also that you use them to
compute some invalid model strengthening
that could happen
when you compute cutting planes uh when
you
perform some pre-solving reductions that
you actually
remove some
integer feasible solutions that are
optimal
[Music]
because you apply uh
yeah arithmetic reasoning that's based
on floating point
um design
um so how do we deal with this um
i started with linear programming
because yeah uh getting exact
solutions to linear programs is
important also for
solving mips exactly um at two
points is essentially so
you may need an exact lp solver first of
all for primal solutions
so certainly for the integer
variables you can always round them and
fix them to a rounded value
but for the continuous variables uh at
the end of the day you need to
somehow solve the remaining lp
uh exactly and that's where you need an
exact a
solver the second point where you might
need an exact lp solver is
for dual bounding and that would of
course be one of the
naivest the most simple ways how to
create an exact
mip solver simply to solve all of the lp
relaxations that you
obtain with an exact lp solver
that's possible but it
is quite expensive but it is would be a
baseline uh
implementation kind of so how would we
solve
lps exactly why is that expensive well
um
the yeah the the simplest idea would be
to just not use floating point
arithmetic right but to use
exact arithmetic which is rational
arithmetic if you're talking about
rational
input data here and there are several
implementations out there
um that simply a simplex method
with rational arithmetic and that
guarantees you exact results
but of course this is
potentially very expensive as
the size of the problem grows
well actually not as depending on the
problem size but rather
as the size of the numbers that you
encounter in the algorithm grows in
encoding length so what you do during
the simplex method and what somehow
inherently you have to do with many
lp methods is you need to uh
yeah you need to invert matrices
so in the simplex method you get a
linear system that comes from
the tight equalities which gives you a
linear system of equations and
when you solve that you essentially you
create a matrix inverse
and there the encoding length of the
resulting solution
can also it is somehow polynomial in the
input data it can be uh strongly
increased
and if this happens uh then the
this naive approach will be very slow
in traversing such uh solutions
um so one thing that people have
realized is the simple observation that
floating point soldiers are actually not
that bad all the time so
um and even if you especially if you use
a simplex method um
they even give you some uh
discrete information exactly what we
call the basis information so which
inequalities are tight and
so here in the right picture that would
be the dashed lines
and if you would now solve this linear
system of equations
exactly you would obtain potentially and
very often empirically that's the case
an exact
optimal lp solution so you
don't even you you simply ignore the
approximate floating point solution that
the
solver has computed and you just
recompute exactly and that's of course
much faster
than using like doing a full simplex
method in rational arithmetic right you
just do the floating point version
which is fast at the beginning and then
only the result is checked
um of course that can go wrong so the
picture that you see here is not always
that nice
the basis might either be infeasible
or it may be sub-optimal and um
then you need to continue and one way to
do so is
the soil approach that's been
implemented in the solar that's called
qsoftx
um we term that incremental
so this is not our approach but when we
improved upon this we call this
incremental precision boosting
and that simply means if you realize
that the basis is not
feasible or not optimal then the
floating point precision that is used um
to perform the floating point simplex is
simply increased
from uh 64 bit to 128 and even further
as long
as or until the floating point simplex
in higher precision
reaches a basis information that can be
verified to be an exact solution and
one disadvantage of this is
that well as soon as you boost the
precision
of course also your loading point
simplex becomes much slower than than
the double precision version
and so uh one
improvement upon that that we have
developed is called
lp iterative refinement and that has a
very similar goal
basically to reach a basis that is
optimal but it doesn't do so by
boosting the precision but it uses some
um
supplementary problems that you can
solve on double precision level in order
to continue
pivoting in a more efficient way
and so these what i've described here
already
is basically algorithms that
use different levels of precision in
order to compute
exact results and this kind of
theme of using different levels of
precision in order to
[Music]
create an efficient algorithm or fast
algorithm
is also used in the mixed integer
setting
so the fastest method here
go along these lines um it's a bit
different
so the the the goal in mixed integer
programming
is a bit different we don't always need
exact linear programming solutions
actually all we need is
exact dual bounds we need
the safe under estimations of our
optimal objective value
and so we do not necessarily need to
solve the ap relaxation
to optimality but we just need to get
such a safe dual bound
and uh so uh there are several
ways on how here you also
gain you you compute an approximate
solution by a floating point
lp solver and then you somehow try to
correct
the dual bound in order to be a valid
underestimation and
there are two things two methods that i
want to mention here
um beyond um which are methods that can
be used
beyond this simple way of using an exact
piece of and the first is
primal bound shift um one way
uh one name for it which is essentially
that you use directed rounding
sometimes also called interval
arithmetic
in order to compute a safe bound
so in order to know what exactly
goes on you have to look at this
dual linear program which i've written
here which is a
bit of a handful technically here
but basically what you have written here
is that you try to compute the maximum
like the tightest underestimation of
the objective function um
that you can obtain by aggregating
the constraints with some dual
multipliers
and so uh basically your floating point
solver gives you a candidate y
of dual multipliers for each constraint
but when you aggregate these constraints
with these approximate dual multipliers
then you will
not be dual feasible the dual feasible
constraints are exactly these equality
constraints that are written here in
this formulation
and so um you need to perform some
correction and the
correction that bound shift performs is
on these
lambda and mu values which
can very easily be shifted when you
have variables which are bounded
and so yeah if we have for instance in
the case of an
binary program with only binary
variables the bounds are 0 1 this all
works very nicely
in the very general case however
this may fail so general mips just may
have unbounded variables and then you
cannot just
do such a simple post processing
and one more expensive method
that was developed in order to deal with
this general setting
is called project and shift
it also performs such a correction but
it
needs a bit more input so it requires
that
at the root node you pre-compute
[Music]
a dual ray so a
vector y lambda and mu that satisfies
these dual feasibility constraints with
right hand side zero
and then you can use later at the nodes
of the subtree
you can use this dual array in order to
[Music]
manipulate your floating point
floating points full solution
to satisfy the inequality constraints on
the dual multipliers because
all these dual multipliers need to be
non-negative
and so such a dual array allows you to
preserve the feasibility of the
dual constraint and manipulate
and basically make all the y's lambdas
and mu's
non-negative um of course there's also
the question how do i
achieve feasibility of this equals zero
equals z
constraint um and also for that i need
to pre-compute somehow matrix inverse to
be
able to perform a projection that's why
it's called project
and so it has this two phases
and so um of course there are many
details but yeah what you should take
from this is
there is a very simple method that may
fail for some problems or
it may fail also for some uh
i mean it may fail at some sub nodes of
a branch and boundary and this is a more
expensive method
which works more generally and what is
not on this slide there's a third method
just a total fallback of using an exact
lp solver
to compute a dual bound
um
this all was combined um
in 2013 or in the years leading up to
2013 too
um i guess what is
what was considered uh the state of the
art
for exact rational mixed integer
programming
um this was a version or an extension of
the skip solver
by uh
and it is such a hybrid precision lp
based branch and bound
where a different of such safe dual
bounding techniques
are implemented and they're used in a
hierarchy
of course you first try to use the cheap
ones and then
the more expensive ones
they have implemented state-of-the-art
branching heuristics
and measured that the result is about a
factor of two to four times
slower on average than uh
the floating point version so this uh
seems to be actually quite um quite a
very good result right
only a factor of two slower also you
have this additional
effort of uh of creating safe dual
bounds
um but one thing that you need to know
about this is
that this is of course a comparison to a
lane branch inbound so
[Music]
this research was performed on
on a version of the solver which did not
include a lot of the sophisticated
techniques that actually make
mip solvers fast today that made
floating point whip solvers fast today
and so while they had the state of the
art in making the right branching
decisions
um it did not include cutting planes
conflict analysis uh resolving or
primary heuristics
and it will also not include the
[Music]
this ap iterative refinement scheme for
solving
uh exact lp relaxation lp realizations
exactly that i've mentioned
and so three things um
uh are now what we have worked on
in the last two years to bring this up
to date
so we don't have exact cutting planes
yet or exact conflict analysis yet
but we have included this iterative
refinement lp solders
we have included rational exact
resolving and we have included
primary heuristics and this is what i
would like to talk about
now in the next section
on what the impact of uh
these these techniques uh on an exact
mib solver are are any que
are there any questions at this point
well i don't see any
questions in the chat what i am thinking
about
at this point in time we would normally
take a short break
it's already 47 yes yes uh yeah
so i'm thinking like maybe should we do
it i mean this is a good point to take a
break
yeah what the what what does the speaker
suggest do we do five minutes ten
minutes
um that's not up to me that i think
depends on the audience
let's go for
eight minutes so we'll reconvene 1855
european time okay thank you very much
five minutes to the hour okay thank you
everybody
so let's see any questions that have
accumulated
meanwhile during the break
anyone has anything that they want to
say in the in the chat or
or unmute and speak
okay i guess there's a question from the
youtube chat
would it be possible to pre-calculate
the worst case denominator ahead of time
and then convert yes bounded
can you repeat the second part of the
question uh
yeah i'm trying to read here the
calculate the worst case denominator
ahead of time
and then convert the bounded fractional
lp into a pure
ilp and solve that using infinite
sufficient precision integers only
[Music]
but you wouldn't then you're so yes lp
into an ilp right
but yes it is possible to compute
the worst denominator ahead of time
that's given
by hadamard's inequality so you
basically have to look at
um i mean a kramer's rule gives you
that the denominators are determinants
of
square sub matrices of the constraint
matrix and these are bounded by
the product of the norms of the column
vectors
um these are is a really bad bound
um so it's
it it's going to be huge um
but you can use that to
multiply the constraint matrix i guess
you
yeah so so i think it would be in theory
possible
i don't think that would work for any
but small problems
okay right now so i guess it's time to
get started again
okay thank you so here's just a slide on
what i've just said like this
are the uh updates that we have made to
the last version from 2013.
um and now it begins a tricky part of
the talk
because it's a part with many
computation results in tables and it's
easy to get lost
i will try to point out what are the
important numbers
[Music]
and my focus here is not to show oh my
god we've got so much faster but really
like
what what have we done in order to uh
get faster and to analyze these results
so this is not a the motivation is not
benchmarking but
getting insight in what costs time and
whatnot
um so the first step that we've done
when we took on the
kind of old proof of concept code was uh
a revision of the basic branch inbound
framework
um which also includes
um uh the use of a
new exact lp solver based on this lp
iterative refinement uh that is we use
soplex instead of qsopx
we have we can now use the project and
shift method more aggressively because
we have a
better lp solver i would say um
and some smaller technical things like
enabling the objective limit
the floating point a piece of and faster
feasibility checks
these are details but so what are the
results you see here
comparison between the original
framework and the new framework
and you see two lines which correspond
to two different subsets these are from
the original paper
2013 so there's one set which is
easy for the floating point solver 55
instances
called fp easy and there's one set
which was identified to be
to have really numerically difficult
instances so where floating point solver
really
runs into trouble and we will now
continue analyzing the results on these
two different subsets
uh you see that we like in the first
columns
solved that we solve more of these
instances
now uh really to prove an optimality
and most mostly you see that the time
has reduced drastically so from 128
seconds to 38
on fb easy and 237 to 46 seconds so
that's a massive speed up
it only comes partially from smaller
trees so you see the number of nodes
have not been reduced so significantly
so really a lot of the
simply no processing time has been uh
reduced and this is also what you see in
the last column the column db
time which is the time that is spent for
these
safe dual bounding methods so for
the algorithms that convert an
approximate floating point
dual bound to an exact same dual bound
and so this is really where the speed up
comes from here because this has gone
down
from almost 100 to around 10 seconds in
the new framework
so this is time times are an aggregate
for all instances or like medium time or
no we what we use uh that's pretty
standard in whip solving are
shifted geometric means so um
in order to account for the fact that of
course for different instances
the magnitude of solving times uh
vary so the geometric mean can handle
that
but then sometimes there's a problem
because you
overweight the importance of instances
with very small running times and these
are actually not the most important ones
so we use a shifted geometric means or
geometric mean on
times where we add like one or two
seconds as an offset
yes okay thanks um
and so because the the speed up has so
much come from
the improvements in these dual bounding
methods here is a
more detailed table which shows you how
much
time was spent for the three different
most important methods and this is this
bound shift which is the super fast one
that may fail
the projection shift which is more
expensive
and the most expensive method exact lb
and
what you see is that um
the so there are many things to see and
i don't want to go into
all the details here but let's focus on
the first line which is the
average calls per node so how often was
one method used and so here you see
that bound shift has been used
much less and that is an engineering
artifact because
we now deactivate downshift when it
fails
very regularly
[Music]
but we also see that primal shift is
called less and
the reason is because bound shift is
actually when it's applied it's more
often successful
because we are a bit more clever about
aborting with respect to unbounded
variables so there are cases when bound
shift can be used also when unbounded
variables are present
and we exploit this now and then most
importantly
exact lp solving is called much less
often and that's one of the most
expensive
techniques and so that also really
reduces the overall running time
[Music]
maybe one strange thing is the second
line this
tells you how much time is spent per
call for these
bound uh bounding methods and there you
see in the original framework
project and shift was i mean these are
small very small numbers
uh 0.002 uh seconds
per call while this is tripled in the
new framework so why would that be the
case
that's a reason is because project and
shift is now
and so in the old framework there was a
working limit
for using project and shift because it
simply could not be applied to
large-scale lps
due to the limited performance of the
exact lp solver
and now with soplex we can actually use
it for
much larger problems but that also means
that the average times go up
but that's actually a good thing so um
yes so so overall we we notice we
need to use the exact ap solver much
less and project and shift
is much more successful
um but yeah let's let's step to the next
part
and that is algorithmically maybe a bit
more interesting and that is
the addition of rational pre-solving
so um let's look at the results first
so the new framework without pre-solving
and then
when we enable rational pre-solving
um we see a
increase in the number of instances that
are solved on both test sets
not huge but noticeable
but most of all we see a reduction in
the running time and the reduction in
the number of nodes
so here it's much more the case that
actually the reduction in the running
time also comes
from the reduction in the number of
nodes and that shows you that
pre-solving does not only reduce the
size of the problem
but it really strengthens the
formulation it makes the
fuel bounds much tighter and then as a
result
leads to much smaller enumeration trees
and you see that uh in the
like on the right side in this
parentheses resolving that
the time needed is really
small compared to the running time so
it's a cheap step to make a big
improvement
um how was this achieved so we've
done this externally by creating a new
software library for resolving
independent of skip
um and one thing that we did from the
beginning is that we simply templatize
the arithmetic type
that is the arithmetic type that is used
so we can simply plug in
gmp um for all of the operations and
then automatically we
obtain a rational resolver
one other nice feature about this
library is that
it allows to parallelize
some yeah the the techniques that are
run
it cannot it cannot parallelize the
arithmetic operations themselves
so you should also not expect that
[Music]
this linearly scales or something or
anything
but it can kind of buffer some of the
computational overhead that you get when
you use rational instead of floating
point arithmetic
and this is what you see here a bit in
this details table so there we have
for each test set um one line for
one thread and 20 threads and what you
see
in the right side exact pre-solving time
column is
that the times are reduced slightly
so from 0.25 to 0.14 on average
which is not at all a great parallel
result
for using 20 threads instead of one
but uh it's still something nice to have
and
uh there are individual instances where
uh the kind of the worst case um
uh yeah running time is reduced
significantly
um one thing that is that you can see in
this table here
is basically how does the exact
pre-solving compare
uh to uh floating point pre-solving and
not only in time
but uh also in the amount of
reductions that it obtains because a
priori it's not at
all clear whether an exact resolver
would have
result in more or less or in the same
amount
of reductions because some reductions
can be applied more aggressively when
you do not need to be
to worry about uh tolerances some will
be
applied more conservatively because you
cannot decide whether something is
exactly like where the two columns are
exactly linearly dependent
it's they're just not and so one
surprising result
here is that actually it's very very
similar
so the number of rounds the number of
fixings the number of aggregations which
you see in these three columns in the
middle
and the number of bound changes for the
easy instances
are identical this is not an error in
the table
and what you see when you look at the
numerically difficult instances
that there are of course differences
and you see on the numerically difficult
instances actually
you find um a bit less fixings a bit
less aggregations and a bit more bound
changes and that simply means that the
exact result that is
truly a bit more conservative and more
correct because floating point resolving
probably just
did incorrect reductions on the
numerically troublesome instances
okay so this is a nice
and they're apparently very very helpful
and important
technique to also have in exact solving
especially for these difficult instances
then let's come to the third algorithmic
part and that is the addition of primary
heuristics
and again let's first look at the
results and then let's look at
how we actually obtain these results so
we compare here again
disabled and enable heuristics
and for these two test sets and the
first disappointing thing that you see
is that the solving time
is barely affected um on american
difficulty it actually slightly
increases i mean
barely noticeable um so why
the well actually this is an effect that
is not
so surprising
um it's something that also in floating
point mib solvers can be observed that
actually primary heuristics
when you only look at the time needed to
solve the optimality
are not very important um so in floating
point heuristics
floating point solvers i think you see
that
they they i think one measurement was
like 14
that they can you can speed up the
solvers by about 14 which is also not a
huge number
um so here we basically have no speed up
uh but what we see
is uh that the time to obtain the first
feasible solution is significantly
reduced
and that's quite interesting because
that makes these solvers also
more useful in practice
and so now how did we actually implement
these
rational heuristics well we did not
implement rational heuristics
um we took a meta approach
by doing the following we execute
floating point heuristics like they
would be executed in a floating point
solver so
they run on the floating point
representation of the problem
and then if they are lucky they
obtain they return a feasible solution
approximate solution
we can first of all check whether we are
lucky and they they are actually
feasible um
often this will not be the case it does
happen sometimes but often not
and then we can try to repair these
approximate solutions simply by fixing
the integer assignment
after rounding the values and then
calling the exact lp solver on the
remaining
linear program
and this is uh potentially of course
expensive so what we do is that we we
buffer we try to buffer
incoming solution candidates uh
until we reach 10 solutions or until
like the
potential improvement is huge so that we
do not actually
pull the exact piece over too often
um so there is a bit of sophistication
in it
one motivation for not re-implementing
all the heuristics in ration
arithmetic is not only yeah because we
were
lazy to do so but because the
rationale between heuristics here is of
course as i've mentioned it
is very similar to the floating point
setting
heuristics here should not be as
aggressive
as possible but they should somehow have
a limited effort
and try to be successful when they can
for a small within a small computational
budget
and that simply means that for instance
running a submit heuristic
in rational arithmetic like
would just is not called for
and so this approach of just running
heuristics in floating point
and then trying to convert a solution
seemed much more reasonable to us
we of course see that this has
limitations especially when we look at
the second line here for the numerical
difficult instances
so uh because um
this is actually the next table yes so
where we in this table you see a bit
more the perfor
how these heuristics or how this
approach performs
and there you see in the second table
that the success rate
is um uh
for the um the
success rate is much lower here in the
very last column
than for the instances which are easy
for the floating point solver as well
and that of course indicates that yeah
running floating characteristics
on a numerical instance is just um
whether the instance is just
is not as representative of the exact
problem
um uh as in the in the
[Music]
the other test set and so for these
numerically difficult
instances it might be reasonable to
think about
designing some more dedicated rational
heuristics
in the future okay so
this was the third part on prime
heuristics we see that doesn't really
help to solve
to global optimality but is very nice in
terms of
getting prime solutions very fast in the
beginning
and now at the end
i would like to show you some numbers on
more recent tests so this was the test
sets that were rather small as you could
see
and so we've also compared now the
full-blown new version with the original
framework on
uh the nuclear 2017 benchmark set which
is the current standard for comparing
floating point solvers
um and uh there you see
well you see similar results than what
we've seen uh
what could be expected from the previous
tables here
so um the original framework
in the first line uh you see like
statistics over all instances that uh
instead of 17 we can solve 47
now to open optimality and for many more
instances we find
actually feasible solutions that's due
to the primary heuristics really
and the running time is also
significantly reduced
not only the running time but also the
gap at termination
in order to evaluate this we need to
restrict ourselves through the instances
where we actually have a finite gap
for both codes for both the
frameworks this is in the second line
there you see
also the gap when average here is
reduced by a factor of 2.
and now what does the last line mean
so the initial line uh averages over all
instances that means also over all
instances where both solvers uh
time out and of course in this benchmark
set
design for floating point solvers there
are a huge number of instances which are
i mean they are even hopeless for
floating point solvers so uh they are
more than hopeless for exact solvers and
so in the last one we
restricted we excluded all the time or
the double timeouts
uh and there you see that the speed up
is uh much larger it's not only a factor
of two like in the first line but it's a
factor of
over six um
yes so this kind of gives you a snapshot
of
the performance impact of yeah these
techniques in the exact setting
and then i have the last uh last table
for you that may also lead
to some further discussion uh as the
jakob has already
uh requested and that is that is in this
new version we've also included
um now the printing of certificates so
what i think is called proof logging in
the set community
so
[Music]
i can tell you more later about how
these certificates actually look like
um they basically encode the branch and
cut tree
also in a bit of a special form um
and here they do this in a very
straightforward way there is not
[Music]
terribly much sophistication in it but
here we simply measured like how much
overhead does this produce and so
uh overhead comes in two ways of course
first of all
overhead in solving time while you're
printing the certificate and then
overhead
to check the suffix certificate at the
end and you see that this checking time
is completely negligible
the reason is because the certificate
encodes all the
information that you that you need to do
so you only need to recompute it
essentially
um but yeah as a
on the downside you see that the solving
time include
increases by a factor of who
almost because a lot of dual multipliers
essentially need to be printed
and not only because of that but also
because some of this information that
needs to be printed
um is not available for
like the fastest dual bounding method uh
this bound shift method
um so this is also why it
does a certificate printing currently
requires
to do more arithmetic work during the
solving
and that's why the time for the dual
bounding so this db time increases um
as you can see um in the db time
columns um we haven't
seen anything about the the proof size
like the size of this certificate no
no i cannot so i don't have any
statistics on that
um i don't think we had
um we impose memory
limits but you know actually so since we
print everything to file there's also
not really a limitation on like
we can now not solve one instance
um but certainly they are they are
potentially long for them
but i mean it's an interesting trade-off
i think that also
for cdcl sat solvers where like some
early formats were writing down
pretty much all of the information
needed um
and that makes for fairly big proofs
that are
are expensive to produce and now i think
the tendency
has been to to shift much more work to
the
proof checkers so the the sat solver
sort of provides the bare minimum
and then dumps a lot of work on the on
the proof checker to reconstruct things
that the proof checker should be
able to figure out um yes i mean as
you see this table says we need to go
exactly in that same direction i mean
this is basically this is the first uh
certificate
system that has been proposed for mip
and uh we do have some ideas on how to
go in that direction that you mentioned
yeah this is definitely a lot to do
there
um yeah so these are just some
statistics uh for this certificate
printing
and then maybe to wrap up now um so
what uh i think has become clear is
that the round of error-free uh solution
of mips is still far from competitive
with state-of-the-art floating point
solvers in
um i hope but
convince you that this is quite an
interesting area of research to
uh to invest time in and also that there
are what you've seen is that there are
no fundamental roadblocks to doing so
so i mean you've seen the the use now of
heuristics and pre-solving
and things it's not theoretically
difficult because it needs to be done
and it can be done of course in more and
less sophisticated ways
but um it's there's no reason why there
should not be
a exact whip solver that is within
a constant
factor of slow down compared to a
state-of-the-art mip solver so
for this old um
solver they measured a factor of two to
four respect to the
plain branch and bound version and i
think that this slowdown of two to four
that can definitely also be kept for
uh when you include all these
state-of-the-art
techniques because most of them are
heuristic in nature
so actually you can perform a lot of
these things not in rational arithmetic
so the the speed up that you gain should
be the same or even more
than in the floating point setting and
uh yes
so with this revision that we've done
now uh this
exact extension of skip will also be
much more easily
um available and usable
so if you i have any interest check it
out
thank you very much for your attention
yeah so the time was just flying
so um i don't know how much time we have
now to go into any further
for the details um but uh i wanted also
to thank you for the
questions they were all interesting
questions so yeah
yeah i did their best to slow you down
but let's see i think the first question
is is maybe
if there i see i missed a question from
mata
sauce in the in the chat unfortunately
and i don't
know longer know exactly what it refers
to is it con
fair to consider this technique as a
form of what we call
pre-in processing and set solving
there's no time step on this i just
missed it
yeah they must be related to the
pre-solving right
and the answer is yes i guess that i
mean yeah so
like yeah make sobers do
pre-improcessing but they call it
pre-solving
any other questions comments
i mean it is getting there i'm certainly
i'm personally curious about this
this uh proof format and what like the
proofs look like but i don't know
if it's realistic to say anything about
it
i mean we do have five minutes right um
i mean there's
uh definitely i can give you a like a
peek
so i think that unless yeah i mean it's
a
it's uh people just log out
and leave when they no longer can follow
so in that sense i guess it's it's like
easier to discreetly slip out of the
door than during the regular seminars i
don't
so then i don't see any questions
uh ah i see a supporting vote for the
proof format and a commitment
to listen for 10 minutes before slipping
out of the door
um let's why don't we why don't we just
go for the proof
proof format yes that's encouraging so
um i think i have to go
yeah i i have i had two things prepared
so i just need to fast
forward now to the proof section
sorry yeah so uh
um that is perfectly fine
so um yeah what's the status quo um
basically most mib solvers do not output
any optimality certificates and the
yeah the reason is is not just laziness
it is
of course there are some difficulties
with it
um and
they go beyond i mean the theoretical
difficulty that you also have in set is
that
you there are no small certificates in
general right um
[Music]
uh unless there's an uh super huge
amount of checking them
uh but practically also in whip solvers
uh
one problem is that uh the techniques
that are applied are very complex and
diverse
um and so encoding them
in proof can be yeah quite a lot of
implementation overhead
and where the certificate form is not
like uniquely defined there are
several ones i mean the most natural one
is certainly the
the tree certificate and this is also
what we
went for in this straightforward
suggestion
so goals would be of course um that a
formal
should be expressive it should be able
to encode all or at least most of the
important algorithmic techniques it
should be simple so
checking should not require a
sophisticated
code where that could contain bugs
itself
and it has to be somehow general
in the sense that it applies to all
mips and not only to a special subclass
which
i mean there have been works for the
travelling salesman problem for instance
in the optimization community
and so um yeah as i said
our suggestion was quite straightforward
so um lp bounce
can be simply certified by a dual
solution that's quite
uh quite simple theoretically
so here you have this a small example of
an objective function and two
constraints on two variables
um and what we
derive as an optimal solution
can be certified by
creating uh using like uh
the right dual multipliers to add up
these constraints
uh to obtain the objective function
so here for instance if you take one
times the first
constraint and minus 1 times the second
constraint
then you obtain 5 minus 3 is 2x
and minus y plus 2y gives
plus y and greater than or equal to
two and here you have less than or equal
to one so that of course turns around so
greater than equal to minus one if you
add that up to minus one gives
one so you obtain these constraint which
must certainly be satisfied by
all feasible solutions and so
they must all be greater than equal to
one so that's just
the plain lp duality and so now if you
provide also a
primary solution then you have basically
a certificate
of optimality and
in plain text syntax this viper format
would look the following
you will first of all specify your
problem by stating
the variables you specify the objective
function
we do this in a very non-human readable
way
by just indices and coefficients
so variable 0 has coefficient two
variable one has
coefficient one um and we do this
sparsely so because yeah uh
later for the constraints we will
definitely need a sparse representation
so we say
here already the objective function now
has two non-zeros
we do the same for the constraints um
there we have to also encode the right
side so greater or less than or equal to
the right hand side of
uh ooh and i think here's an
arrow that should be a one here
um and then we somehow should tell
you what we want to prove um so here we
want to prove that
uh the range of the objective function
is from one to infinity
so um we now derive
one constraint which is the objective
function constraint
uh two x y x plus y green equal to 1
which is encoded here like in
g1 for the right-hand side then two
non-zeros
the zeros variable has two and the first
variable has coefficient one and we also
have an abbreviation for not always
writing this same pattern which
corresponds to the objective function
and then what you need to tell the
checker
is how did you obtain this kind of the
certificate for this individuality
and there we say
we have a keyword saying lin which is a
linear
aggregation of constraints
here it says that we aggregate two
constraints
namely the zeros constraint with a
multiplier of one and the first one with
a multiplier of minus one
and then we simply if you want to
also you have a primary solution in
there
then we just need to add some section
for how the primary solution looks like
that's of course uh
simple and then we can not only give
this range one to infinity but
yeah that the objective function value
is actually equal to one
so i guess that is very clear
so very very straightforward um so
now we've not talked much about cutting
planes but of course cutting planes
should be
somehow possible to encode in such a
certificate
[Music]
and for that we need some sort of
rounding operation
so here's an again a different
uh problem and um the class
so so many many cuts for instance
algomarie cuts can simply be
derived by uh forming again an
aggregation
such that all integer variables have
integer coefficients
and continuous variables don't appear
and then round up the right hand side
and we do this here in two steps
first of all we create the aggregation
here y greater than equal to minus
one-half
when you use one-half and minus one-half
for the constraints
and then we explicitly have a rounding
step of saying
uh run round up the right-hand side
this is a separate constraint and this
you can then continue of course also
and you can use the previously uh
generated cuts
and so in plain text syntax that would
look like this we have then a keyword
r and d which corresponds to rounding
the right hand side
and then we're not only cutting but
branching
is important so how do we encode these
junctions
so we did not want to explicitly encode
a tree structure
so really to have a relationship of
parents and children and whatnot
because that is just a pain to keep
track of for a checker
and also there are cuts that might
actually use these junctions
that are not in the tree um and so we
simply have lines that
uh encode the disjunctions that we have
these are
not certified these are just a list of
disjunctions that
we may use later on these are just
general linear inequalities
and then you can derive
something based on these yeah assumed
distinctions on these
assumptions and
then of course you may end up with
derived constraints which are valid
only with respect to some of these
assumptions and so
what you need is somehow a reverse
operation which tells you
i have now proven something for two
disjunctions
for a disjunctions like for two
assumptions which uh
as a union
form like the whole solution space uh so
and you have two uh identical
uh derivation constraints c3 and c4
and that both are valid um
uh without the opposing assumptions and
so we have
kind of an operation which we called
unsplit so
we had two parts from a disjunction and
derive certificates uh to derive
constraints for each of them which are
the same and then
we unsplit them and say they are valid
now for without these assumptions
uh and so uh this would look like
i don't have the plaintiff syntax here
but i think you get the idea
[Music]
and yeah so we only have basically four
reasoning
types i mean one is not even a reasoning
type it's just an assumption
we have no explicit free structure but
we
as a result we can check each line
sequentially
depending on the previous lines
um and theoretically
the question is now can we express
sort of all the reasoning that whip
solvers do and on the cutting plane side
um the what the right picture here
should
tell you is stolen from a paper that
proves that basically most
interesting parts
can be expressed as so-called split cuts
and split cuts are simply
cuts where you use the disjunction and
then prove
the validity of an inequality for both
sides and then
you uh yeah proven the validity
for uh without a disjunction
and so um for instance comradery cuts
can also be proven like this
and so in some sense for cutting planes
this certificate would be
quite expressive and i think also for
things like
resolving and propagation techniques and
not counting symmetry it would work
or for other techniques um and um
yes i think that was now everything
that i had prepared anyway for this and
uh
so question question about certifying
uh different types of cut rules so
uh if you want to do mixed integer
rounding
cuts then is it
right that you would somehow do like uh
do a disjunction or like branch on some
variables and then certify and then
what does it call like unsplit or or how
do you like
how do you do a in general like a mixed
integer rounding cut and how efficient
would a
the certification step for that be yeah
so we've
not uh so we've not implemented anything
on cutting planes
so um the reason is because the current
version of the exact skip simply does
not have exact cutting planes
yet um and so we have no comparison on
like now what would be the most
efficient
uh way to do so
but uh uh yes for for mixed integer
rounding you would definitely have to
create
uh the disjunction and so
there is certainly an overhead so you
should not expect that
you can now use one or two lines for
expressing
the validity of a certifying an
extinguisher rounding cut
um yeah because there's like one one
you can there's a trade-off for so what
you accept as your primitives like if
you expect to
yes to use mixed integer rounding cuts
often then should you like put them in
your base language and just say that we
accept them to be true or
or do you prefer i mean the the the
rounding rule you had is like extremely
clean and simple
right it's it's clear that it's valid
whereas
for me the rounding cuts are still very
mysterious
yes yes now um so i think what we need
in the end is sort of a a hierarchy of
uh certificate formats we need one that
is
that can contain a lot of special
reasoning types just in order to allow
the solver to print them very quickly
without having to recompute anything
but then i would say checking these
safely without bugs is probably a bit
tricky
and so we would need probably some tools
to convert this into a more plain format
like the one that i've
presented now such that we can get a
certificate that is of course
potentially larger but can be
checked with much more certainty so i
think this is
how we would go about it
there's a question in the chat but i
also i see
kieran are you we see your video is that
because you want to ask
yes one more before i have to run off
and eat dinner um
does pre-processing for mip ever
introduce or remove variables for
example
it does certainly remove variables
it does also aggregate variables in the
sense that
you say x can be expressed as a linear
combination of other variables and then
x is removed and
replaced by this yes if you thought
about that you could prefer
that it does not very much introduce
additional variables
right okay formulations wouldn't that
like introduce variables
or no um yes but that's
not the kind of standard repertoire of
what's used in whip solvers oh they're
not that common
no we do so uh i mean they are a big
area of research in mip
but uh they are not automatically
created
i think uh maybe the thing that would
maybe come closest to is what we already
discussed this
binarization of integer variables of
course if you perform that
that would create new variables yes
and the certificate format is not
[Music]
laid out for this okay thanks
any other question on
proof vlogging and we do have a question
that i certainly
won't drop regarding the uh how map
solvers stack up against
sat and pseudo boolean solvers but but
before we move there um anything else on
the proof logging
if people are interested i'm trying to
monitor
so i what i would really say is that in
the mip community here
we are very much in the beginning and
certainly the success of i mean just the
methodology that is available in saturn
in surah boolean solving
it's an inspiration for me to improve
the situation here
okay so practice
more about solving and there was some
some discussion going on
in the chat as as you were giving your
talks i'll just
read it quickly and then i'll let you
comment on it
so started by asking this is perhaps a
naive question if i'm trying to solve a
large
set of pseudo boolean constraints so
zero one integer linear constraints
when if at all would it potentially be
beneficial to try out the mip solver say
skip or grobby
instead of a pv solver like rounding
saturday sat4j
to which i answered the answer is very
painful
most of the times as things are looking
now
not always for sure but commercial mip
solders are very very good and even
skipped beats surrounding saturn
saturday on the surugulan competition
benchmarks from
2016. there are problem domains where tv
solvers are better though and for cnf
problems so problems in conducting
normal form mip solvers
tend to be pretty bad i think and then
sopratic
wrote back i see are there some rules of
thumb
to help choose is it mostly the enormous
amount of
engineering that has gone into skip
grubby that explains this
this is of course not to discount the
tremendous effort that has gone into
rounding
saturday as well so that's the
discussion we had and now i guess it's
your turn to comment on this
yeah so i would uh i would subscribe to
what you said i think one rule of thumb
is
if it's an optimization problem go for a
mip solver
i think they're just more geared towards
optimization problems
if it's a plain feasibility problem
i mean pseudo boolean solvers might have
more have a
shot at being the fastest
um one bottleneck for
mip can be if the problem are really
huge and
dense for instance i don't know if that
happens in
pseudobullion or if you only consider
sparsity but if they are really dense
then the linear programming simply may
become a huge bottleneck and so mib
solvers may not be very good
simply because yeah they don't even get
started
and maybe just one more thing that
doesn't answer the rule of thumb
question but i think
we of course need to acknowledge that
the comparison between
sort of boolean solvers and mip solvers
is not
fully fair in the sense that mib solvers
are not
exact solvers right so the boolean
solvers can
are numerically exact while mip solders
are not they may also
return a solution that's yeah i don't
know slightly infeasible or that
sub-optimal
if you have numerically double some
problem formulations
and so probably the the more fair
comparison um
would be to compare it to this exact
version of that i've presented to you
and then also things might look a bit
brighter for booty and i don't know
depends on how important the exactness
is of course for your
uh problem for your boolean problem
i think it's definitely the case that
this current state of the art
as you said ambrose that for for
decision problems like rounding set and
stat4j would have a shot for
optimization
you know we really struggle um
there is um i
i think this is an interesting you know
if we would all have met at the simons
then one thing i think we would have
been talking about
is i think there are a lot of
interesting ideas on the mip side
and some other quite interesting idea on
the sat slash suitable inside and you
can think about
whether it would be beneficial to
combine the two for instance the
conflict analysis on the pseudo boolean
side is potentially quite interesting
um but but this this idea of solving lp
relaxations and adding cutting planes on
the mipsite certainly seems to be very
very powerful
um and i think it's probably i mean mip
solvers are used
a lot in industry to i think every
self-respecting airline is like i guess
running nip solvers every day well not
now because they're not flying now but
you know pre-pandemic they would
schedule their flights and their stuff
and everything
yeah so i think probably like the man
years that has that have gone into
mip coding is you know
waters of magnitude i think more birth
so but i i think there's there's
room for for doing work at the lucky at
the intersection of sat
and mit and that's sort of where
pseudobunnies always would sit and then
you should also not forget about
mac sat solvers that are really really
good but they're
essentially i mean mac sat solvers are
essentially pseudo boolean solvers but
where you insist
on that you only want to deal with cnf
conductive normal form
so that's a third paradigm to to check
out and we do have i mean this is
shameless self plugs but there are some
recent papers um involving my research
group among
others that where we can see that if you
take ideas from max at
from pseudo boolean from mip and you mix
and match and
interesting things happen
um other questions
comments i mean this was an amazing talk
this was
super useful and interesting
and especially the things you appreciate
your patience
i can say so i don't know if there would
be a
analog on the
mip side one thing that has been very
important
for certifying solvers for like graph
solvers which
kieran mccreesh has been working on but
he ran away so one thing that was really
crucial there was that
sometimes the solver it sort of
you you mentioned something analogous
that sometimes the solvers knows
things but maybe it doesn't know how to
express them in the proof login
formalism
like you know a fact but if you have to
write down a derivation then maybe you
don't have that information
handy and you need to do more
definitions
and and this was a big big pain for
graph solvers because they do bit
parallel operations and at some point
they just realized that
okay the domain of this variable is
empty i have to backtrack
but you don't know why that happened
because you did a lot of bitwise ands
and ores
and suddenly something happened and then
like a key
feature of sat proof logging that turned
out to be
very fruitful to lift to graph solvers
was
this concept of reverse unit propagation
clauses
so basically this is just a fact so
it's easiest to explain for clauses but
a reverse unit propagation
clauses like given the state of
knowledge that we have right now
here is a clause that i claim is true
and the way
to verify it is i don't tell you why but
the proof checker can check it
by asserting the clause to false so take
the minimal assignment that falsifies
the clause
and then it just checks that indeed this
propagates the contradiction
and now saying that since assuming that
the clause is false propagates the
contradiction
then you know the clause is valid and
you can uh
just for for clarification or as a
question from my side so this of course
requires that
uh you do have somehow a verified set
solver to
run this right you must have a set so
that you trust i must have it
the algorithm for unit propagation i
mean unit propagation is a very very
limited kind of
it's an extremely stupid it's not a
general set called ah yeah
okay unit propagation okay so it's only
unit propagation that you
you know you you only fire when a clause
has all literals
falsified except one then you set the
next one and you do this until
saturation
and if this leads to contradiction
then you accept the clause but if it
doesn't then you just say well i don't
know
you know then you then it might still be
true but you're not accepting it
so it's it's like extremely limited form
yes sorry stefan
as you already said ambrose the main one
could also think of having like
multiple layers and you have like the
unit propagation
layer higher up which is more easy for
the solver to use
but if you want more trust then you can
like
transform transformed the propagation
into some simpler language that doesn't
do any automation but really writes down
explicitly what you need to do to get
these
steps of reasoning so i mean one idea
that we had i don't know
if yeah that goes
but so to do something analogously um
that these dual multipliers for the lp
certificates
are actually you do not need to print um
if you do it correctly then you can just
use an ap so that to recompute them yeah
uh i think it would be i think a similar
similar thing
so what i'm i've also been thinking
about that but i fear that this would be
too expensive somehow like to run the lp
silver for verifying every step somehow
but maybe it also depends on the
application i guess in in mip solving
where the result was obtained from
lp solver in the first place then maybe
it doesn't matter too much
because like you're again like in the
same running time as the solver
yes that's like but also like i mean
when
when like sometimes we are trying to
handcraft kind of linear combinations
for writing down proofs and this is
really annoying thing to do
yeah this is also what i would like to
especially for all these different
pre-solving techniques where you
yeah you know that's true but writing
this down is a dual proof is just
annoying
so i think we should probably you know
start thinking about wrapping this up
there is
one more question i think in the youtube
chat which i interpret as follows
i don't know if i'm interpreting
correctly but when you're branching in a
mip solver
so something that people on the theory
side have been looking at is
branching on generic uh
linear inequalities like you take some
some some linear combination
you know vector a times vector x and you
branch on whether this is larger than b
or smaller equal b minus one are these
kind of general
branching decision something that map
solvers would do
or is it just like more theoreticians
thinking about this
um it has been investigated in the
literature
uh currently solvers don't do this
there are several reasons why it doesn't
seem beneficial
so the first one is simply it's much
harder to figure out
a general dysfunction so you just need
to spend much more time
was there a question
yes so anyway the the first bottleneck
is degree of freedom is huge
so um and there are no no good ways to
actually limit this currently
we need better ideas and the second that
if you use general disjunctions then the
lp solving gets slower
because if you do variable branch and
you basically you fix variables so you
reduce the size of your lp
when you would do general constraint
branching you add
constraints so you slow down the lp and
that doesn't seem to pay off in practice
also of course
the dual balance could improve
but there are several papers which have
tried
i also have one ah i see
so on behalf of all the audience let me
just thank you again for a fantastic
seminar this is this is great
uh and yeah thank you very much for your
patience and attention and we should say
that we have another miptop
coming up i think i'm struggling to
think now
uh i don't remember when i believe
oh uh yeah
let's see so yeah on may 11th we have
another miptalk
uh and of course before that we have uh
so
next this i should have said at the
outset but next uh
tuesday we're talking about answers at
programming which is another paradigm
uh that is sort of goes beyond set and
then in two weeks from now
something that we brief touch
briefly touched on today and emily we're
in two weeks from now we're going to
talk about maximum satisfiability
solving or max
ad solving which is sort of also pseudo
boolean solving or zero one interior
linear programming
with another name and focusing on
constraints in conducting normal form
but i think this is it for today
thanks everybody
thank you very much